over the Christmas period I picked up
this game for my PlayStation Atari 50
which is a sort of interactive history
of the Atari games consoles misses out
the stuck but the Atari games consoles
and arcade games and one of the things
it does is it emulates the game so you
can actually play them there's been a
new Jaguar emulator written by Richard
Whitehouse which has then been released
for the PC as well and so I thought what
would be an interesting thing to do
would be to actually look at how we
would write an emulator for a game
system or a computer or anything really
first thing to start is actually we need
to know what's in the system that we
want to emulate we're not going to build
a complete emulator because we don't do
tutorials on computer file but we'll
look at things so let's start with a
system and let's keep the Atari theme so
let's grab a 2600 start off thinking oh
it would be really hard to write an
emulator then when you actually start
looking at it you think actually this is
really easy and then when you try and
actually make it work for every single
bit of software that's ever been written
for it you realize it was hard in the
first place so you can get something
going that will run simple software
quite easily but to get the most out of
things like the 2600 or an Amiga or an
Atari St or whatever it is even a modern
PC lots of software tricks are often
used and getting them to emulate
accurately
can be really really hard and that's
where things get interesting but let's
break this open literally and see where
we get started
there we go so it's not pushing it peace
and then we've got the circuit board
and most of this is just stuff to make
it appear on the TV screen so we've got
the TV modulator over here a few buttons
for input and output sockets for the
joysticks on the back a few switches
that's power input quite useful doesn't
work without it but the main things that
we're interested in if we're trying to
build an emulator are these three chips
here the one in the middle this one is
the CPU it's a variant of the 6502 CPU
so we'll need to emulate that and by
emulate I mean we'll need to write
software which does exactly the same
thing for the CPU drills won't give them
the same code
um this one over here is the wonderfully
named Riot chip that's short for Ram
input output and timers uh chip here and
we'll need to emulate that as well and
we've got down here the television
interface adapter the Tia chip which is
one that produces the graphics and so on
that actually gets displayed on screen
of course the other thing which is the
game the cop the Atari is well known for
is that you have the cartridges which
you slot into here and actually all the
cartridge was was a ROM chip which
contained the program so your actual
program code was in the cartridge so
that was there and then the CPU was here
and the ram was in the chip here to go
actually and you had the wonderfully
high amount of 128 bytes of memory we're
not going to go into the details of how
the 2600 works that's another video and
we should probably already be covered
part of it but we need to know where
those things were so that when we
emulate the CPU and we write a
particular memory location or read from
a particular memory location we know
whether we're getting data from the
cartridge getting data from the RAM and
the riot chip or whether accessing some
other Hardware
that's attached to it so the first thing
that we need to know when building an
emulator is
what's the memory like this is pretty
much exactly the same things you need to
know when designing a computer or
designing a games column in the first
place you need to know where things are
going to be so you can build the
hardware to decode it we're not building
Hardware we're writing software but we
need to do the same sort of thing in
there
exactly that's exactly what we're going
to do we're writing software that
pretends it's Hardware so on the 2600 we
have address zero down at the bottom we
have FF FF up here yes I know the 6507
CPU variant in the 2600 only has a
limited number of address pins so only
goes up to one FFF but in terms of the
6502 it's still try and access the high
addresses to fetch things like the reset
Vector we'll come back to that so at the
top we would have the ROM
and that would be a line to the top of
it is a ffff f
um so that the reset vector and things
are in the right place so the low 128
bytes of that are for the Tia chip and
you access that with those addresses the
next 128 bytes are your RAM 128 bytes of
it and then it addressed two zero zero
zero or so in HEX you have the rest of
the riot chip that you can access there
so we now know where things are in
memory and we can relatively easily
duplicate that in a program the ROM
cartridge if we've got the code for it
we can load that into an array and we
can access the bytes from that
relatively easily again the ram we can
load that into an array access the bytes
right bikes into that when we Access
Memory there easy to do as we said when
you start off it looks complex as you
start to break it down and so I thought
oh this looks relatively easily one
array two arrays
easy to implement then it starts gets
harder again for things like the input
output device is the Tia the riot your
keyboard your mouse will be doing a
computer or something they don't
necessarily memory locations but when
the CPU reads from there you can write
software that basically says if it is
this location
call this routine to process the value
that's being written or call this
routine to produce the value that's
being read
from that location
so the memory side of things
starts off looking straight forward the
other thing we then need to implement
is of course
our CPU and then that's normally in
Hardware would talk to the memory via a
databus and an address bus so the
address bus will contain the address of
what it wanted to access and the data
will be funneled over the data bus as we
said we can emulate that
our emulation the CPU can produce an
address and then we can then fetch it or
store it based on the data that we want
to access
so the question is the real question is
how do we emulate the CPU
well to do that we need to understand
how the CPU works you need to understand
what registers it has what internal
values they have for we can store things
we need to know what it does when it
starts up we need to know what the
instructions are and the effect that
they have and then we can write a
program that does exactly the same thing
so let's have a think about the 6502 CPU
and the only reason we're using that is
because it's dead simple
that's based inside the 2600 or
something it's also inside the NES the
Nintendo Entertainment System
the snares use the later variation of it
the
658c16 I think it was
um and so on and the 6502 has been
around for donkeys years pet the
Commodore 64 the BBC micro or 6502 based
if I remember correctly or variance of
it should we say and things so the 6502
based CPUs are dead simple we've got
three registers a X and Y and they all
store eight bits so we've got an 8-bit
for that I've got eight bits for that
and we've got eight bits for that we
also have a stack pointer which we will
call S which is also eight bits long
but the 6502 does something Slightly
bizarre in that it always prepends a one
to it so your address is all four
between one zero zero and one FF in
hexadecimal in memory which Maps quite
nicely to our display here because our
Ram starts from FF down to 7f but the
way it's implemented is it also appears
at 100 to 1 FF so you can use the Rambo
for just general purpose things and also
for the stack which you need for the CPU
to work properly things like calling a
subroutine will only work with the cpu's
got a stack for that to store the return
address in and things it's the way the
CPU works when you call a procedure
effectively it needs to store where to
go back to and it does that by putting
it on the stack so that you can then
pull it off when it's finished again
starting to get slightly complicated
because we thought these things only
appeared here
but actually they now appear at the same
thing so there's two addresses that can
access the same thing so we need to
write our software that emulates the
memory to cope with both set of
addresses and get the same thing because
if you access them either value you get
the same result
starts to get slightly more complicated
still not that complicated yet we'll
come to that
so we've got our axy we've got our stack
pointer which is one and then the value
in there
we have a program counter
and this is 16 bits long
I'm here and that stores the address of
the next instruction we're going to
execute the CPU works by fetching an
instruction from memory executing it
then fixing the next one and it knows
where to get it from based on the
program counter here so that's a 16-bit
value and then finally we have a set of
processor Flags which are generally
referred to as p and which are eight
bits long
and depending on the instructions they
get set with specific values so we can
break these down for example we have a
flag n
which is set if the instruction produces
a negative result so if you say subtract
one number from another and it's
negative
that bit in the practice of flags will
get set to say that it's produced a
negative result there's another one
which is set if it produces a zero
result
um there's one that happens if there's a
overflow a carry I'm not writing these
in the right order because one tells if
there's interrupts enabled there's
another one that tells it if it's in
decimal mode which is a pain in the neck
to implement and then there's one that
tells it if the break has happened of
course you need to make sure if you're
implementing it that they were in the
right order so that's basically the
internal state of the 6502 CPU it is
relatively straightforward and we could
easily write a program to store this
state
we could have a variable called a which
stores the value in the a register we
could have a variable called what do you
think Sean uh well I would have called
it B but they called it y so is it Y no
it's X so yeah we'll have a variable
called X to store the x that is a
variable called y to store the Y
register the variable called s which
stores the stack pointer a variable
called PC which is 16 bits long which
stores the program counter and a
variable called P which can store the
processor Flags so again relatively
straightforward we can create these just
use normal variables to implement them
then we need to think about what does
the CPU do when it starts up with a 6502
what it says happens is no idea what's
going to be in the registers except it
will go and fetch into the program
counter from memory locations
fffc and fffd so it'll fetch those two
bytes and put them in the program
counter as the first address it's going
to access which is why our ROM
cartridges are mapped in at the very top
of memory because then those addresses
are in the ROM and the ROM can specify
where it wants to start its program in
there in the games console and so when
we write our program the first thing
that we'd want to do is to set the
program counter to equal the location in
memory
at address
0xffc
oops I missed an F in there
and then we just need to do some bit
shifting
to get the location at zero xff
D it's a little engine CPU hate Little
Engine CPUs big ending is the way to go
I'm a Motorola fan and we'll shift it
left eight bits to get it into the right
place so we fetched the address of the
first instruction we are emulating what
the CPU do the hardware that implements
it here when it comes out of reset when
it starts we'll take the address that's
in memory which will be in the ROM
cartridge on this system or the
different computer system will be in a
different place gets the address there
puts into the program counter and then
goes and fetches the first instruction
so what our program would need to do and
we'll write this in pseudo code is fetch
instruction at PC so we fetch the byte
that's there on the 6502 the
instructions are by long on different
CPUs there are different widths if
you're trying to emulate the x86 CPU uh
good luck to you they're an absolute
nightmare they can be anything from 1 to
15 bytes long pain in the neck to
emulate so we can fetch the instruction
there and that gives us what's called
the op code we then increment the
program counter so it's pointing at the
next instruction we then need to emulate
that particular instruction and the way
we can do that is look at the op code
and then if the opcode has value 0 we'll
do one instruction if it has its value
one we'd do a different instruction it
has value two we'll do another
instruction so we could use something
like a switch statement and just say
switch zero do this which one do that
switch to do this to have the same
effect as the CPU would have when that
instruction is executed so let's have a
look at a very simple instruction this
one has the value A9
which if you were to look at up in the
instruction is the load a register
with an immediate value which just means
it follows it in memory
so if we saw the value of A9
we would then write some code that would
read the next value from memory
which we've already incremented the
program counter to point to so we'd read
that and then we would take it and write
it into our variable a one other thing
we need to do is we have these flags
that we need to set based on the value
of the variable a
so for example if this is 65
it's not negative so we'd set that to be
false it's not zero so we'd set that to
be false and because of the way that LDA
is specified in the documentation for
the 6 over 2 we don't change any of the
other flags in the flags register and
the status register so what we'd have to
do for every instruction is write a
piece of code that would do the same
thing for a x y s p c and P that the CPU
would do and as long as it has the same
effect when we then execute the next
instruction because the state's been
updated to have the same thing that the
hardware would have that instruction
will have the same effect now you might
think there's 256 values in a byte that
means I'm going to implement 256
routines
actually it's not quite as bad as that
because a lot of the
um instructions are similar so for
example the one we've got here the A9
routine we can actually break down
to a set of bits the end one zero
and then you have three bits we'll call
them B
here which specify how the addressing
mode works and we'll have three bits a
here that specify what the instruction
is so these three bits will tell you how
to fetch the value from memory is it an
immediate value do you read it from
another memory location and these will
tell you what do you do with that value
so it might be in this case LDA which
means we load the accumulator the a
register with it it might be that we add
the value on to the a register or we
subtract the value or so on so actually
you can split this down and say well I
need to write eight different routines
to do the actual operation and eight
routines that fetch the value for memory
and then 30 years only 16 routines you
have to write not what looks like it
might be 64. so it's not quite as bad as
it seems and some of the other ones will
have similar effects as you do that
so it starts to look like writing it
wouldn't be too hard
but we've only considered the CPU and
what x it's executing remember we said
that the CPU is actually talking
to the other chips on the system so it's
talking to the right chip and it's
talking to the television interface
adapter to cause things to appear on the
screen to access the joysticks and so on
to know what you're doing uh as you're
playing the game and this is where
things become more complicated because
each of the instructions takes a certain
amount of time to execute
and the hardware is doing things it
takes a certain amount of time to
execute if you go back and watch the
video where I looked at how you wrote
software for 2600 one of the things you
had to do was change the registers in
the television interface adapter at
exactly the right Point as it was
traveling across the television screen
to change color to set things up to
appear on the right point in the right
line if you
mean right it'll be at a different point
to where the television interface
adapter is and so it'll have a different
effect of what appears on screen it
might execute the right code but what
appears on screen wouldn't be what you'd
expect it to be so you actually have to
write the code here and the code that
emulates the television interface
adapter or any other Hardware in your
system so that you get them working at
the same speed that they're in lockstep
if you want to get exactly the same
effect now for something like a games
console that's really important so that
the games work fine if you're just
wanting to run a program
um say something like a word processor
it's probably less important you could
probably write an emulator for say a BBC
micro that could run a word processor
run basic without worrying about that
you could provide the data when you got
to it which key's been pressed for
example you could output the data onto
the screen and display it and it would
work fine for something like that
because it's not so tightly coupled
between the timing of things but when
you you go to things like gaming
and sort of you talking to other bits of
hardware and so on then you really have
to make sure that the timing is
absolutely right and that's where things
get interesting because something like
the 6502 is relatively straightforward
in terms of targeting if you look at
something like the 68000 which was used
in the Amiga or the Atari St or the Sega
Game savior Mega Drive saber Genesis and
things
you find that the length of time and
instruction takes Can Depend depending
on the way the hardware is built on the
instructions next to it the way the
hardware is implemented means that some
instructions may take longer at certain
times than others on the Amiga for
example if the CPU could be stalled
while the graphics Hardware fetch values
in certain cases and so on and so you
had to really make sure that
everything's balanced what this means is
even though you're emulating a CPU which
is about one megahertz or something like
this eight megahertz on an Atari St or
Amiga say
is relatively low spec the actual CPU
power you need in the computer that's
running the emulator can be considerably
higher because you have to make sure
each of these things are happening in
the right amount of time so they appear
on screen at the right amount of time
and everything's happening and it can
get a lot more complicated very quickly
as we said you can create a very simple
emulator it's a relatively
straightforwardly all you have to do is
make sure the right values end up in the
registers and in memory at the right
time
but to actually emulate a more
complicated system
it gets quite complicated quite quickly
and often these things aren't documented
so often you will have to sort of write
tests that run on the real Hardware
assume you can get access to it that
test and find out how things actually
work out in practice because sometimes
the documentation is wrong sometimes the
designers of games and things have push
this so far that they're beyond what the
actual Hardware designers expected
things to do so some of the things you
end up trying to emulate
are specified the CPU and things but
actually the way that interacts with the
other bits of Hardware some of it's
documented and some of it is just sort
of a byproduct of the way things have
been built and to make sure the software
has exactly the same effect in the
emulator as it would on the real
Hardware you need to make sure that
that's those same side effects happen
often at the same point in time
and that's how writing an emulator
becomes more and more complicated you
have to do tests to find out how the
hardware actually works in practice
rather than just the way it looks like
it should work and you need to keep all
the different parts of the hardware
synchronized not necessarily in terms of
real time but certainly in terms of in
relation to each other so if the real
Hardware takes this long to display a
line of graphics on screen and the CPU
executes that many instructions in that
same amount of time then your emulator
needs to emulate that number of
instructions in the same amount of time
it takes the graphics emulator emulation
to display those things and so you need
to keep track of how many cycles it's
often referred to each instruction takes
place with and then you can advance the
graphics by the same amount and so on as
you're going through even if you're
writing a simple emulator though there
are certain things you need to keep
track of for example on the Apple M1 Max
the Macos running on there can emulate
an x86 64 CPU very effectively and but
even there they've had to be careful
because the memory model of an armed CPU
is different from an x86 CPU what I mean
by that is x86 has certain
design decisions made which means that
in this case this will happen
particularly if you have multiple
threads running alongside each other
there's a strict ordering of when memory
will get written back which the arm CPU
doesn't Implement so if you're emulating
an x86 CPU on an armed CPU you have to
make sure that you also emulate that
memory ordering and things in there so
you can get something going relatively
quickly that emulates the CPU but to get
it totally accurate you often have to
really delve deeply into how the
hardware actually works and then
Implement that in your software
maybe it's going to work for 90 of the
internet or 80 for the internet
but it's going to die for the other 10
or 20 this is the ossification chance of
getting the train within three cycles
and then if you go any longer then it's
going to take you longer you know your